without objection the clerk lays before
the house
the following resolution
house resolution 22 resolution electing
a member to a certain standing committee
of the house of representatives
without objection the resolution is
adopted and a motion to reconsider
is laid upon the table
without objection the chair lays before
the house
the fouling resolution house resolution
23 resolution electing a member to a
certain standing committee of the house
of representatives
without objection the resolution is
adopted
and a motion to reconsider is laid upon
the table for what purpose
does the gentleman from maryland seek
recognition
madam speaker i ask unanimous consent
that the committee on the judiciary
be discharged from further consideration
of hres
21 and asked for its immediate
consideration in the house
the clerk will report the title of the
resolution
house resolution 21 resolution calling
on vice president michael r
pence to convene and mobilize the
principal officers of the executive
departments of the cabinet to activate
section 4 of the 25th amendment to
declare president donald j
trump incapable of executing the duties
of his office
and to immediately exercise powers as
acting president
for what purpose does the gentleman from
west virginia rise
i object objection is heard
pursuant to section 5 a 1 b of the house
resolution 8
the house stands adjourned to 9 a.m
tomorrow
you